[Musica]
quando ho ricevuto l'invito e la
comunicazione del tema di questo tedex
evoluzione da biologo ricercatore e
scienziato quale suono la prima persona
a cui ho pensato non poteva che essere
lui Charles Darwin e la sua teoria
dell'evoluzione biologica Ecco Oggi io
vi racconterò come l'evoluzione
biologica sia in qualche modo simile a
rivoluzione di vita personale che ognuno
di noi deve affrontare raccontandovi la
mia rivoluzione
Darwin ha descritto Questa teoria nel
1859 nel libro intitolato le origini
delle specie qui Darwin afferma che
l'evoluzione di nuove specie animali
avviene Grazie all'accumulo di graduali
e in apparenza poco significativi
mutamenti mutamenti casuali e che
possono essere positivi o negativi ma
positivi o negativi in base a cosa per
Darwin il filtro che determina siamo un
cambiamento sia positivo o negativo è
temperatura ambiente in cui l'organismo
vive in pratica un animale con un
mutamento sfavorevole rispetto
all'ambiente non sopravvive Viene
eliminato invece un animale con un
mutamento favorevole sopravvive e prende
il sopravvento rialzando completamente
l'animale con il cambiamento negativo
Questa teoria sostituì il suo piantò
completamente la teoria precedente di
ramarca il quale affermava che fossero i
bisogni che un animale a modificare in
qualche modo l'organismo consentendo
loro di adattarsi all'ambiente
per spiegarvi meglio la differenza tra
queste due teorie vi faccio un esempio
diventato famoso quello delle Giraffe Le
Giraffe vivono nelle savane che sono
ambienti aridi e Poveri d'erba Quindi
queste povere giraffe sono costrette a
bloccare le foglie degli alberi alberi
spesso molto alti e quindi queste povere
giraffe sono costrette a sforzare
continuamente il proprio collo per
raggiungere queste foglie ecco per la
marca è proprio questo sforzarsi della
giraffa che le permetterà di allungare
di poco alla volta il proprio collo e
questo cambiamento acquisito Grazie
all'uso verrà trasmesso alle generazioni
successive le quali a loro volta
continueranno a sforzarsi ed
allungheranno ancora di poco il collo
fino ad arrivare alle attuali giraffe
Ecco ora fermatevi un attimo e provate a
pensare se questa teoria fosse vera e a
tutte quelle persone che provano ad
allungare determinate parti del proprio
corpo Ecco Queste persone avrebbero pure
ragione di tentare di farlo ma è meglio
che torniamo a Darwin
per Darwin nello stesso momento grazie a
mutamenti casuali che oggi sappiamo
essere dovuti a mutazioni casuali del
DNA coesistevano giraffe dal collo lungo
e giraffe dal collo corto Le Giraffe dal
collo lungo erano proprio adatte alla
Vita in quanto riuscivano a raggiungere
più facilmente le foglie degli alberi
mangiavano di più crescevano più forti e
generavano più figli Ecco quindi che nel
tempo Le Giraffe dal collo lungo più
adatte alla vita presero il sopravvento
rimpiazzando completamente Le Giraffe
dal collo corto
quindi per Darwin possiamo dire che
l'evoluzione è data dall'incontro tra
l'ambiente e la casualità e che
quest'ultima in particolare gioca un
ruolo fondamentale ora se ci pensate
Questa teoria era veramente
rivoluzionaria per il tempo qui si parla
del XIX secolo in quanto Darwin afferma
che l'evoluzione non è più lineare e
determinata da un'entità divina Ma
corredata al caso
ora inoltre se ci pensate
evoluzione biologica teorizzata da
Darwin è in qualche modo simile
all'evoluzione di vita e personale che
ognuno di noi deve affrontare
un'evoluzione in cui l'ambiente dove
nasciamo cresciamo viviamo gioca un
ruolo fondamentale e dove ogni tanto
arriva il caso che decide di fare quel
cavolo che vuole lui
oggi in particolare vi voglio parlare
dell'evoluzione del ricercatore
universitario e in particolare la mia ma
che credo ben rappresenti anche quella
degli altri 150 mila ricercatori
italiani
dire che nella vita ho fatto ricercatore
nasconde dietro di esso un percorso
lungo e tortuoso fatto di gioie ma è
sicuramente di tanti fallimenti
la mia evoluzione inizia così proprio
con il ruolo fondamentale giocato
dall'ambiente la mia classe del liceo Da
del liceo scientifico Da tutt'ora su una
strada nella quale a mercoledì mattina
si svolge il mercato paesano ricordo
ancora le mie edizioni di biologia
appunto del mercoledì mattina che erano
accompagnate dal suono di questo giovane
ragazzo mendicante di nome Sasha ricordo
quella musica un po' strimpellata come
quella canzone d'amore che ha fatto da
sottofondo è il mio innamoramento per la
scienza e la biologia era il 2006 E in
quegli anni si iniziava a parlare di
cellule staminali queste cellule
precursori che potevano diventare
qualsiasi altra cellula del nostro corpo
ed io trovavo incredibile come una
minuscola cellula potesse diventare un
neurone una cellula di muscolo o una
cellula di fegato e i ricercatori
fermavano che queste cellule avevano
infinite potenzialità terapeutiche e
potevano essere impiegate per la cura di
diverse patologie Ecco io quel giorno lì
mi dici figata Io voglio andare a
lavorare con queste cellule diventare
ricercatore Ecco il ricercatore non sono
diventato ma non ho mai lavorato con una
cellula staminale
Fatto sta che concludo il liceo e ora
sarete pensando Beh se sarai iscritto a
biologia non so Medicina o Chimica No in
realtà mi scrissi ad ingegneria Ma come
dopo tutte queste belle parole cioè lui
staminali patologie verbrati se hai
scritto ad ingegneria Voglio farvi
notare che all'epoca era così
e se ce l'ho fatta io ci speranza per
chiunque
e in qualche modo le pressioni sociali
si fecero sentire mi sentivo ripetere
Iscriviti ad ingegneria che troverai
sicuramente lavoro che per carità vero
se c'è qualcuno in sale che vuole
iscriversi ad ingegneria ve lo consiglio
fatelo Fatto sta che ecco che l'ambiente
in qualche modo influì sulla mia
evoluzione e mi ritrovai scritto ad
ingegneria inutile negarlo che fu un
anno terribile mi sentivo completamente
un pesce fuor d'acqua e finalmente
ripresi in mano le redini della mia vita
e tornare il mio vero amore alla
biologia furono in questo caso poi
cinque anni entusiasmanti
A parte un esame di biologia vegetale
che dovete ripetere ben tre volte
Infatti è vero che amo la biologia ma
odio la biologia vegetale
Fatto sta che arrivò velocemente i 2012
anno fondamentale anno della tesi che al
momento fondamentale per capire se si
vuole o no continuare con la carriera
del ricercatore si entra e si vive per
la prima volta il laboratorio e la vita
del ricercatore
entri ti aggiri spaesati questo luogo
sconosciuto fatto di strumenti mai visti
dai nomi impronunciabili e vorresti
provare un po' di tutto ma vi assicuro
non sai fare assolutamente nulla e
scopri per la prima volta che fare
ricerca significa avere idee e ipotesi
da testare sperimentalmente e che la
maggior parte delle volte gli
esperimenti non vengono e tutto ciò su
cui avevi puntato non ha assolutamente
senso
conosci per la prima volta quello che
diventerà un Fedele compagno di viaggio
da cui non divorzierai mai più il
fallimento Ecco la fortuna per noi
ricercatori è proprio questa imparare a
convivere per la nostra carriera con i
fallimento siamo estremamente fortunati
ma nonostante tutto riesco
e mi laureo nel 2012 vedete le priorità
per la ricerca
fondamentale
Sì è molto importante vi assicuro questa
ricerca
Ora però sono convinto Dopo questo
momento Voglio diventare ricercatore
universitario e lo step successivo
quello obbligatorio quello del dottorato
di ricerca
quando in Italia dico che ho fatto da
fatto un dottorato di ricerca la gente
mi guarda e dice
Wow Bravo Bravo Complimenti seguito da
secondi di silenzio e poi la fatidica
domanda Ma che cos'è sto titolato di
ricerca ovviamente tutto accompagnato
dall'età di cogesto
e dottorato di ricerca è quel percorso
che ti forma per diventare ricercatore
possiamo un po' definirlo come la scuola
dei ricercatore e in Italia dura dai 3
ai 4 anni e in questi anni si portano
avanti dei propri progetti di ricerca e
si cerca di dimostrare sperimentalmente
se le proprie idee sono vere o false
sono anni estremamente difficili fatti
di tantissime ore passate in laboratorio
di qualche gioia e di tanti fallimenti
con un unico obiettivo finale che lo è
un po' per tutti i ricercatori così come
lo era per Darwin che è quello di
pubblicare su riviste scientifiche
internazionali i propri risultati di
ricerca dovete considerare la
pubblicazione come il principale
criterio di valutazione per un
ricercatore
Fatto sta che supero anche questo
periodo e pensate poi che alla fine si
deve discutere una nuova tesi appunto la
tesi di dottorato e pensate che i
termini inglese per definire questo
momento è Defence Che significa difesa
perché quel giorno ti ritrovi di fronte
ad una commissione composta dai massimi
esperti del tuo settore che cercheranno
in tutti i modi di mettere in dubbio le
tue idee e ipotesi e di trovare i punti
deboli di ogni tuo risultato Ecco io
difesi valorosamente più o meno in
questa battaglia il la mia tesi e mi
sono dottorato nel 2016 Finalmente una
foto normale
magari e purtroppo no sono solo
all'inizio iniziano Infatti ora gli anni
definiti da post doc che altro che non
sono che gli anni dopo e dottorato
questi sono anni fatti di contratti di
un anno due anni se siamo estremamente
fortunati ma anche di sei mesi e pensate
che questi anni di precariato
Specialmente in Italia possono durare 6
8 10 anche 12 anni e sicuramente avrete
sentito parlare dei problema dei
precariato della ricerca Ecco questo
problema nasce proprio qui per questo
tipo di contratto e in questi anni in
questi anni l'obiettivo L'unico
obiettivo è quello di continuare a
migliorare il proprio curriculum con
l'obiettivo poi di partecipare a
concorsi per ottenere finalmente delle
posizioni più stabili Ecco che questi
anni bisogna fare esperienze all'estero
Bisogna cercare collaborazione con altri
gruppi di ricerca si deve supervisionare
studenti
dottorandi si devono tenere al seminari
lezioni si deve continuare a pubblicare
cosa che vi assicuro assolutamente non
facile e bisogna scrivere e vincere
finanziamenti di ricerca che non si sa
mai escano anche dei soldi per pagarti
lo stipendio
come potete immaginare sono anni
estremamente difficili ad un certo punto
anche io inizio ad avere dei dubbi
ho scelto il percorso giusto è la strada
giusta Quella che ho scelto per me
l'idea cercare qualcosa di più stabile
iniziava a tormentarmi la precarietà
aveva iniziato a logorarmi dentro
iniziavano ad avere più certezze e dubbi
aumentavano e lavoro si stava fermando
non riuscivo più a pubblicare non
vincevo nessun finanziamento e da lì a
poco In laboratorio ci serve neanche
stati più soldi per pagarmi praticamente
tutto ciò per cui avevo lavorato fino ad
allora sembrava pronto a svanire non
vedevo più futuro e vedevo è passato
come
un inutile susseguirsi di fallimenti e
di inutili traguardi raggiunti
in una parola e il buio
Fatto sta che lì una cosa che mai avrei
immaginato in vita fece capolinea della
mia mente la depressione
di quei momenti non ricordo molte cose
ricordo però quegli occhi affranti Ed
isolati di chi ti vuole bene
quegli occhi impronti in cerca di rimedi
e soluzioni per farti tornare te stesso
guardo di qua perché di là ci sono i
miei genitori anche no di qua c'è anche
la mia compagna non so più dove guardare
adesso
Fatto sta che ne sono uscito e non so se
voi crediate o meno nel destino Ecco non
lo so nemmeno io Fatto sta che lo stesso
giorno in cui ricevetti una proposta per
un lavoro in azienda e stavo per
abbandonare questo maledetto mio primo
amore ricevete anche la comunicazione
che avevo vinto un importante
finanziamento di ricerca
era quel successo che cercavo da anni
Quel successo che poteva finalmente Dare
una spinta alla mia carriera da
ricercatore lo vidi come un segno del
destino o meglio era il caso che era
tornato nuovamente a farsi vivo nella
mia vita pronto a farmi evolvere
ripresi forza e passione per la ricerca
e la biologia e Fury che nacque anche un
nuovo Me chiamato Samuel Science che la
fusione tra il mio nome Samuele e
scients scienziato appunto che il nome
che utilizzo nei miei profili Social
dove mostro tutto ciò che vi sto
raccontando oggi e dove cerco di essere
un punto di riferimento per tutti quei
ragazzi e ragazze che stanno
intraprendendo questo percorso ed essere
per loro in qualche modo un supporto
degli inevitabili momenti difficili
ora sono sicuro che durante la mia
presentazione qualcuno di voi avrà
pensato Ma chi io sta facendo fare
questo qua di farsi tutta tutta smazzata
no
Ecco una domanda che vorrei porre a voi
è Quanti di voi vanno al lavoro felici
Ecco io nonostante tutto nonostante le
mille difficoltà amo il mio lavoro il
perché penso sia racchiuso in questa
parola giapponese yuken che ha diverse
interpretazioni ma una in particolare
credo racchiuda tutto ciò che muove la
passione di noi ricercatori
yugan indica il fascino di tutte le cose
in penombra o meglio è l'emozione che
proviamo Al pensare alla bellezza di
tutto ciò che ancora sconosciuto nel
mondo di tutto ciò che è misterioso ed
imperscrutabile e che noi ricercatori
con le nostre ricerche vogliamo
finalmente vedere e far vedere al mondo
Ecco io credo che come noi ricercatori
ognuno di voi è la propria vita sta
ricercando il proprio juken quindi ho
piacere di concludere augurandovi un
buon viaggio nei mondi che ancora non
conoscete Grazie
[Applauso]